our subject for this evening figs
do not bear berries what did i say
fig
not bear berries
[Music]
by the word of the lord were the heavens
made
and all the hosts of them by the breath
of his mouth
for he spake
and it was done
he commanded
and stood fast
for by him were all things created
that are in heaven and that are in earth
visible and invisible
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were
created by him
and for him
and he is before all things
and by him all things consist
god is good
and all the time
now who is this him for by him were all
things created that are in heaven and
that are in earth visible and invisible
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were
created by him
and for him and he is before things and
by him all things consist who is this
him now don't answer me
think for ten seconds
because i don't want you to give me a
wrong answer on the sabbath
you can do that on wednesday not on the
sabbath now who is this him
i heard god and i heard jesus
now you can't bring a conflict between
god and jesus
but we have god the father am i right
we have god the son am i right we have
god the holy spirit
which one specifically is referred to in
the passage i just read
jesus
i don't want to preach two sermons but i
may never see you again so let me give
you everything i can
listen to john chapter one
in the beginning was the word
and the word
was with god
was god question for you how many people
are in that verse
you're taking too too much time come on
how many
i forgive you this once how many
we're on youtube and facebook and
people are watching
listen to the verse again listen
microscopically in the beginning was the
and the word was with
and the word
how many people in that verse
[Music]
listen again
in the beginning was
the word
and the word was
with god stop give you half the verse
how many people in that
two
so far
look at verse two the same was in the
beginning with god who is the same
the word
so how many people in verse two
two
now look at verse three all things were
made
by him
now we have one
did i lose you
or did you lose me
let's find each other
christ is the creator
but he created as an agent of the father
the smile just fell from off your faces
let me explain that
christ created at the request of the
father
he did it for the father by the way
christ is savior as an agent of the
father
christ has always been an agent of the
father so while it was jesus who said
that there be light and there was light
but he did it
as an agent of the father so in that
sense the father may also be referred to
as the creator when nebuchadnezzar said
is this not great babylon that
i have built
did he lift one brick
no who built it the architects but at
his
command therefore he correctly said is
not this great babylon that i have built
did you build did you build are you
planning to build a church yes but who
will actually build it for somebody else
but at your command
and payment consequently
jesus created as an agent of the father
but i want to lift up
jesus
when you lift up christ you lift up god
the superstar of the bible is
christ
christ and he said
search the scriptures for in them you
think ye have eternal life for they are
they which testify of me but wherever
christ is glorified is my words
the father is glorified
and so jesus says i am the way
the truth and the life
no man
cometh until father
by me
no man have seen god at any time
luke john 1 18 the only begotten which
is in the bosom of the father he
has declared him you cannot know god
unless you study jesus
let me say it again
the only way to know god
is to study jesus
and so when philip said lord show us the
father and it sufficeth us john 48 in
verse 9 jesus saith unto him have i been
so long time with you and yet has that
not known me philip finish the verse he
that hath
see me come on i've said the father the
only way to see god is to look at jesus
not because they're the same person
but because they're precisely a light
they're two peas in a pod if you look at
one
you've seen the other
i have a friend he's a minister in
california he has a identical twin when
i first saw the twin
i thought i was talking to my friend
because i could not when that when i was
told this is his brother i was shocked
so i wrote the brother name and i said
this is spiritualism because i thought i
was talking to you
but it is your brother absolutely alive
the tone of the voice the haircut the
more everything precisely a lie and i
was just baffled befuddled bamboozled
and bewildered i just could not
understand it but yes when you see jesus
finish my words
seen the father
all right
is there anyone with us who is not the
seventh who dismiss your hand
anyone in the building you're not a
civil evidence nice your hand all right
i'm sure there's someone online who is
not the seventh-day adventist thank you
very much for joining us and may the
lord bless you torrentially in all areas
of your life and put a double blessing
on your children as several day
adventists we're always honored to have
guests among us we really are so if
you're with us online thank you and may
god bless you so much you will look
forward to fellowshipping with us again
i'm grateful to god for this honor of
being with you i first met you online a
few days ago and i look forward very
much to seeing your lovely faces and
they are lovely thank god for that
and so may the lord use me for his glory
i mean that sincerely and i will try to
make the truth as simple as i possibly
can so that you will respond to it and
that will put a smile
on god's face i'm grateful for the
little children little children
understand much more than you suspect
the same way they quickly learn what's
wrong they can quickly learn what's
right are you following me let me say it
again the same way
children learn very quickly what's wrong
if properly taught they can learn just
as quickly what's right and so i'm
grateful always for little boys and
little girls who are in the congregation
wherever i go to preach i always
encourage people don't have children's
church when i am preaching i want all of
them right there in front of me
because they will learn something
that
lies and god is always happy when
children give their lives to him
all right our subject for this evening
figs
do not bear berries what did i say
thing not bear berries you want things
go to victory the bible tells us that
before i get into the message
please
well you have already been reverent
continue to be reverent at the presence
of god for those of you at all preserve
reverence i say all the time the
wholeness of god does not change simply
because you're sitting on a couch in
your bedroom somewhere listening to the
surface god is always holy in a church
in the most holy place in the holy the
backside of a mountain in the case of
moses wherever you encounter god you
encounter holiness
god loves reverence and respect
you go to a courtroom you sit down you
don't talk
because that judge
can send you up the river you know what
i mean and so you're very quiet you
don't play on your phone you don't
gossip you don't talk to your friend you
say quietly in a courtroom because
you're scared of that judge
now god does not use scare tactics but
god is the judge of the universe
does he deserve our reverence come on
say yes all right number two
while i'm speaking pray for me and say
lord put your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth what a privilege to
have god touch you not to kill you but
to put his words in your mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i
have put my words
in thy mouth i've often said sometimes i
listen to preachers on television you
know he's telling that to listen i said
lord please shut that man up
don't kill him just shut him up
or her
they're both genders and god doesn't do
it because god is so merciful i'm glad
i'm not god there wouldn't be so many
people alive on the earth anyway i said
god shut that man up because of what
that man is saying and so ask god to put
his words in my mouth favor number three
think
thinking is hard work
it is hard work
that's why a lot of people don't think
it
thinking takes effort
it really does but god calls upon us to
think isaiah 1 18 come now let us do
what reason together you see god will
come down
i next to you
what happened
talk to me what happened
your parents told you he was no good why
did you marry him
now you're crying
what happened cain killed god came down
why are you upset
let's talk adam's sin adam where are you
let's talk it's always god coming down
because the sinner never wants to talk
to god
so god has to make the first move i
thank him for that
salvation requires the first move from
god
the one who did not sin
did nothing wrong
he moves first now we
when someone offends us
we back up fold our arms you move first
that's not the way god functions god
says the innocent person you move first
to function that way we have to have the
mind of
jesus yes yes and the bible says let
this mind be in you which was also where
in christ jesus and that's no joke
that's not symbolic language from
revelation that's literal we have to
function with the very mind jesus had
when he was on this earth in a human
form let's pray father in heaven use me
as an instrument i pray i offer myself
to you without reservation
if i've offended you forgive me father
put your words in my mouth your ideas in
my mind the humility of christ in my
heart
bless everyone listening in person
touch them where they have a need their
god put a double blessing on all our
guests and all the children
father if anyone listening to me has
coveted
tonight pray for my heart their god and
other aches and pains bring relief to
your people
father
wherever people are watching bless those
countries particularly our country now
father
use me i pray please in the name of
jesus christ i pray let everyone say
amen and amen this side what's the title
of the message too slow that side
figs do not be
you got to move fast you see when the
israelites were told to eat the the uh
the passover
meal they had to eat it how
standing up so you could move fast are
you following me so sometimes you've got
to move fast must name the first book in
the bible this side too slow that side
okay
you know we all say i love god that's
true but i like god
he is a nice person
[Music]
you sin against him and he forgives you
you slap him in the face he forgives you
you spit on him
he forgives you you call him a wine
bible as they call christ he forgives
you
you know you you steal his tithe he
forgives you you marry three women he
forgives you
he is a nice
come on say amen for god
i look forward to his face
i just want to see god
and jesus
i don't know if he'll ever see the holy
spirit but
god the father
jesus my guardian angel who's standing
somewhere
i want to see these beings
all right
let's uh go to genesis chapter 12.
genesis 12
first book of the bible
written by whom
moses yes
genesis chapter 12 and i read from the
king james version of the bible my
favorite but when i study i use a
diversion so if you have a different one
please don't panic
genesis 12 reading from verse 1
the bible says now the lord had said
unto abram
get thee out of thy country and from thy
kindred and from thy father's house unto
a lamb that i will show thee
and i will make of thee a great nation
and i will bless thee and make thy name
great and thou shalt be a blessing
and i will bless them that bless thee
and curse him that curse of thee and in
thee shall all families of the earth be
blessed
let's look at three
very closely
and i will make of thee and i will make
i will bless them that bless thee
curse him the curse of thee now finish
the first with me and in thee if you
have james thou
all
families of the earth be blessed
question for you why did god call
abraham
why did god call abraham
listen to verse 3 again and i will bless
them
that bless thee
and curse him that curses thee and in
thee finish the verse shall all families
what is all families
the whole
world will be blessed question for you
why did god call abraham
to be a
blessing that's why he called you
let me say that again i'm talking to
people and to myself our natural urge is
to put myself first are you following me
okay
god called abraham
not for abraham's sin
but to be a blessing to other people
of course that blessing was the gospel
which peter makes very clear in acts 3
25 and 26 to turn away every one of you
from your iniquities that's the great
blessing of the gospel salvation
which god and the father developed
abraham was called to be a blessing i
want you to observe before
abraham hundreds of years there was
something called the flood
god made adam and eve and they were
perfect
what happened
sin
one word sin that's the word that
explains quote 19.
that's the word of explains the wars
that go on right now there's so many
wars most of them are not even reported
on television they're no longer
newsworthy
sin explains earthquakes
sin explains floods
sin explains famine
sin explains genocide sin explains
divorce sin is the reason for everything
that causes suffering on this earth sin
adam and eve
sinned
god had to put them out of the garden
with the promise of salvation through
jesus christ
we move from adam and eve being expelled
we have the patriarchs who were born we
have seth we have um
enos we have keanu mahalali we have
jared we have enoch we have methuselah
we have limit we have noah the first 10
patriots adam being the first
the next catastrophe we have is the
tower of babel
the people who built the tower of babel
descended from the eight righteous
people who came out of the ark
you didn't hear what i said
go to genesis 7 quickly
i can't see that clock very clearly what
time is it
how many do you have to go to work in
the next five half an hour okay all
right so stay where you are okay what
book did i say
one chapter
let's put as i continue speak through me
god that i may glorify you to the best
of my ability in jesus name i pray amen
listen to genesis chapter seven verse
one
the lord
turn to noah come thou and all thy house
into thee are for thee have i seen what
righteous before me
he called noah and his house all eight
noah his three sons noah's wife the
three wives of the three boys they were
righteous now out of those eight
righteous people came the builders of
the tower of
somewhere along the line they drifted
from god
god had to come down
and he confused the languages and
genesis of
scattered all over the earth
after that catastrophe god decided to
call a family
and he called
in the book patriots and prophets page
125 paragraph one we read these words
listen carefully
after the dispersion from babel what is
a dispersion
a scattering very good
after the dispersion from babel
idolatry again became well nigh
universal what does that mean
common
what's idolatry
worshiping idols whether they're
physical or not
idolatry again became well know
almost every was practicing idolatry
she goes on to say and the lord finally
left the hardened transgressors to
follow the evil witches while he chose
abraham of the line of shem and made him
the keeper of his commandment for future
generations
god saw the whole world
and god found one faithful family
abraham's family i'm not saying
abraham's extended family they were
worshiping idols as well joshua 24
verses 1 and 2 they worship idols
abraham's
ability
and god called him he didn't call the
father tyra but here okay because when
you see a good thing follow it are you
following me so when naomi was leaving
moab
when abraham left lot went with him when
you see a good thing follow it
and so god called abraham not tyra
but hero came with him and he died in
here
the last verse of genesis chapter 11
and god decided now to work through this
man and his and as that is why god is
called the god of is he called the god
of abraham methuselah and noah
what is he called the god of abraham
come on isaac and jacob why because
beginning with abraham god decided to
work through a special people but for
the purpose of reaching how far the
whole
in your classroom
you were there
not to get a degree in physics first
you were there to represent come on tell
me quickly
as rarely as abraham was called to be a
blessing you're in that classroom of
that office to be a blessing to
advertise the goodness of
god now something is what
yes all right
by faith anyone who accepts christ
becomes a child of
but a child of
abraham let's go to galatians 3.
[Music]
galatians in the new testament for those
of you struggling to find it
galatians 3 is read verse 7 we'll read
verse
nine and we'll read verse
29 of galatians three
who has it
ah god bless you
we have a scholar to my right
galatians 3 yeah verse 7
nobody answered the guest preacher
all right must be the culture all right
galatians 3 verse 7. someone on this
side read for me
they annoy therefore if you are the king
james version that they which
[Music]
are
the children of abraham
but the bible says
therefore that they which are of faith
the same are the children of abraham
which means the same way god called
abraham
to be a blessing finish my words
he is called the children of abraham to
be a blessing read verse nine
so then if you have the king james
version nice and loud so then
there is be of faith are
blessed with faithful abraham now in
verse 29.
if he be christ then are ye abraham's
seed and is according to the promise all
right
which means a child of abraham receives
the same commission that abraham
received what was abraham's commission
[Music]
be a blessing
and that blessing as identified by peter
in acts chapter 3 verse 25 26 was the
gospel of jesus christ lived in the life
and preached all right
the same way god called a special family
in the days of abraham
god was called a special family in these
last days
they are also the seed of abraham
and he has given to them
a special message
who can guess what that message is
the three
angels messages
where they found
revelation chapter
verses
6 through 12.
the three inju now
before god sent the flood by whom did he
send a warning or a message come on
quickly
noah
before god destroys sodom and gomorrah
by whom did he try to warn tomorrow or
sorrow lot
he spoke to abraham first then lot
before god destroyed nineveh by whom did
he send a warning
jonah
what am i trying to tell you before god
destroys
he sends a message
before god destroyed jerusalem he sent
messages by
prophets prophets prophet god does not
destroy then explain there's a saying
shoot first and ask questions later god
does not function like that god sends a
warning then he shoots
but he does not want to shoot
we are coming to the end of this world's
existence and god has sent a warning
or a message
and it's called the three angels
messages revelation 14 6-12 i want us to
look at the very first message let's go
to revelation 14 we'll read from verse 6
our subject
fix
do not bear
berries
we look at the first message revelation
14 reading from verse 6.
you have that say amen
read with me and i did what if you have
the king james version read out loud and
i saw
another angel fly in the midst of heaven
having the everlasting gospel to preach
unto them that dwell on the earth and to
every nation and kindred and tongue and
people sing with what kind of voice a
loud pause we must not hesitate to
preach the sabbath
we must not hesitate to preach the
possibility of victory over sin we must
not hesitate to preach the divine nature
of jesus christ along with the human
nature we must not hesitate to praise
the eternal nature of the law of god
we must not hesitate or speak with a
soft voice to preach the second coming
of jesus christ
saying with a loud voice and saying what
fair god come out
give glory to him for the hour of his
judgment is come and worship him that
made heaven and earth the sea and the
fountains of waters that's the first
message let's look at that message we
look at the second element of that first
message what is the second element
element
oh that's the third
what's the second element
for god and give glory to you that's
element number two
i want us to look at give glory to god
as i continue figs do not bear
berries
how do you give glory to god
okay he said fair god give glory to him
worship him that made heaven and earth
but we have three things
give glory worship they're all connected
but they can all be studied
you give glory
to god
before we answer how can we give glory
to god let's answer the question what is
glory
let me pray again fathers i continue
teaching your blessed people
teach me on the spot in jesus name i
pray amen
let's go to exodus 33.
who has it who has it
yes in my bible it is
who has exodus 33 why are you so ah
my friend again
we read from verse 18
moses is talking to god and he makes a
request to god do you have that passage
if you have my version read with me and
he said i beseech
show me thy glory now moses wanted to
see the glory the face of god
now we know that by the way god answered
in verse 20 they can no man see my
face and lift that's what god told him
but listen to what god said in verse 19.
what did god say i will
make all my goodness to pass before thee
and i will do what proclaimed the name
of the lord before thee and i will do
what
have mercy be gracious to whom i will be
gracious and will have mercy on whom i
will have mercy god said i will show you
my name
in the bible what does name represent
come on
cells with a c then an h
then an a then a c then a t then an e
how many twos do you need
character
name represents
listen to god again i will make all my
goodness pass before thee and i will
proclaim the name of the lord
and i will be gracious to whom i will be
gracious and will shew mercy on whom i
will show mercy and he said thou canst
not see my faith there shall no man see
me and live so while moses wants to see
god's face it seems to be the case god
decided to show him his character
now let's go to chapter four
of exodus chapter thirty
it's twelve eighteen
mic improperly
keeps going in and out
chapter thirty four
five
and the lord
stood within there and proclaimed the
name of the lord
and the lord passed by before him and
proclaimed the lord the lord merciful
and gracious come on long suffering come
on abundant in goodness and truth for
you keeping mercy for thousands
forgiving in negativity transgression
and sin that will by no means clear the
guilty now let's pause right there god
gives uh
a view
of what he's like
goodness
merciful abundant goodness and truth
long-suffering forgiving iniquity
transgression of sin god shows moses the
kind of person he is
in the book god's amazing grace page 322
after ella white writes god's glory is
his character
god's glory
is his character now go with me to
second corinthians chapter three let's
read verse 18 our subject figs don't
bear berries
second corinthians three verse
he said ii corinthians
chapter 3 verse 18
do you have that
someone on the left said yes no one on
the right answered me
do you have right
okay
but we are with open face
beholding us in a glass what
come on
the glory of the lord are changed into
one
the same image
from glory now what does that tell you
about image and glory in that verse
i want
okay hand in hand that's a good that's a
good answer
someone else
image glory what can you tell me about
those two words in that verse
listen to the verse
but we all with open face
beholding us in a glass the glory of the
lord are changed into the
same image what's the relationship
within glory
they are who said that
they are the same
and otherwise said
from glory to glory simply means from
image to image or from character
to character
the glory of god
is his character
having said that
how now do we glorify god
let's go to john 15.
first mike was cutting in and out this
one is giving feedback
we will soon work that out do you have
john 15
let's read from verse 4.
you have john 15 verse 4
if you have my version read with me
abide in me and i in you
as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself except it abide in the vine no
more can ye except you abide in me verse
5 i am the vine here the branches he
that abideth in me and i in him the same
bringeth forth much fruit
for without me
you can do nothing listen again to verse
five
i am divine yeah the branches
he that abideth in me and i in him read
the next few words for me the same
bringeth forth
much fruit what's our subject
figs do not bear berries and figs of
fruit bears the fruit now jesus said if
you abide in me you will produce much
fruit
for without me
you can do nothing
we're called upon them to do what
first of what we just read in john 15 5
we're called upon to do what
verse 5 of john 15.
if i keep waiting for you we'll be here
till 6.
what are we called upon to do in john 15
bear fruit
let's go now to verse 6.
if a bran if a man abide not in me he is
cast forth to the branch and is withered
and men gather them and cast them into
the fire and they're burned if you abide
in me
and my words abide in you
you shall ask what you will and it shall
be done unto you now you read verse 8
for me i'll keep quiet read my version
pause
now we're trying to answer the question
how do we glorify god listen to verse
eight keep reading sister herein
that he may bear much rule come on
your hearing is my father glorified how
that ye bear much fruit
then how is god glorified by the
reproduction of the character of christ
in us
so shall ye be my disciples
a disciple is not simply someone whose
name is on the books
a disciple is someone who understands
his or her mission is to reflect christ
do we do it perfectly no are we supposed
to grow towards that yes
but let's learn something else about the
fruits
we're called to bear fruit let's go to
galatians five
read 19 to 23 of galatians 5.
and i really hope you read with me if
you have my version you're so quiet
you must be cold
you have galatians 5
from verse 19
now the works of the flesh are manifest
which are these now we have two words
there works and
flesh keep those two words in mind we'll
find the two opposites when we read the
different lists now the works of the
flesh are manifest which are these
adultery fornication uncleanness
lasciviousness idolatry witchcraft
hatred variants emulations wrath strife
seditions heresies envyings murders
drunkenness revelings and such like
those are the
[Music]
words of the flesh keep in mind works of
the say that again works of the one more
time come on works of the flesh now
go to verse 22
you read for me my version
stop
what are the two opposite words to works
and flesh
fruit and spirit
for all the sins we read in verses 19 to
21 there are works
let's finish that list in 22 23 but the
fruit of the spirit is come on love joy
peace long suffering gentleness goodness
faith meekness temperance stop
shortlist
the other one is
the first list are the works of the
the second list other
of the
who produces the first list
the flesh
who produces the second list
the spirit not you
now
we have what looks like a problem
go back to john 15.
quickly quickly quickly
someone said i'm too hard on my
congregations so let me be nice and give
you half an hour to find john
15.
you have john 15.
let's read verse 8 are you there
my king james people read for me herein
is my father
uh-huh come on becky
wait a minute what is that verse calling
you to do
[Music]
what did we find out in galatians 3
22-23
who bears those the spirit
now let's resolve the conflict
it is the spirit
that bears fruit
out of us
let me say it again
it is the spirit
in us
that produces
love
joy peace long-suffering gentleness
goodness faith meekness temperance now
go back to galatians 3. you hitchhike
into the bible i hope you don't mind
galatians 3.
let's look at
verses 19 to 21.
let's look at the first four words of
gerst verse 19
or the first few words now the works of
the flesh are manifest which are these
what are the two words we highlighted
earlier
flesh and
no no no no what are the two words we
highlighted in verse 19
works and flesh
in other words the flesh can only
produce what
give me some examples
yes the whole list
that's all the flesh can produce
because the flesh
cannot produce what
but give me the language give me the
give the two opposites the flesh cannot
produce what
the fruits of the spirit
now
the spirit
finish my words
cannot produce come on
the works of the flesh
that's why jesus says that which is born
of the flesh
and that which is born of the spirit is
spirit the flesh cannot produce what we
find in verse 22 23 love joy peace long
suffering gentleness goodness faith meek
the flesh cannot produce that
and the spirit never produces adultery
fornication and cleanest lasciviousness
are you with me saying yes or no
in my thing my mistake my fault
now
if you call the flesh
figs
what can it not produce and you call 22
23 berries
the fig
cannot produce
love
joy
peace long suffering gentleness goodness
faith meekness temperance
the fig of the flesh cannot produce
there
many of us
and i have done this myself but don't
tell anyone we've misrepresented god
given god a bad name are you following
me
even though the ninth commandment said
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
and we often bear false winners against
christ who in his humanity is
our brother our neighbor remember
commandment number three thou shalt not
take the name of the law of thy god in
vain you claim to be a christian you
live like a demon and we've all done
that from time to time
a fig tree
can only bear
come on thinks
the berry
vine can only bear
berries
the works of the flesh
we have that terrible list
the fruits of the spirit
we have that list
we started to answer the question how do
we glorify god
john tells us by bearing
fruits
what are they love joy actually love
produces all the others
are you with me out of love comes joy
long suffering gentleness goodness faith
meekness temperance against such there
is no law the law of god cooperates with
those fruits
but there's a law against all that we
read in verses 19 through 21.
you didn't get what i said let's go over
it again
are you at verse 19 of galatians 3
read with me my people you're all my
people but those are the king james now
the works of the flesh are manifest what
does manifest mean
evident give me another word
obvious
the works of the flesh are
obvious they are manifests and then we
have the whole list adultery fornication
all to be done to 21
the fruits of the spirit
must also be what
manifest
you cannot be a christian in disguise
you cannot be a christian incognito
are you following me
no you're not following me
are you following me or i believe you
you cannot be a christian in disguise
and you cannot be a demon in disguise
because the fruits of the demon will
come out
you can plant a tomato tree and put up a
sign oranges
when it grows
what will come up
there a lot of demons with a sign behind
them christian
and then you realize wait a minute this
guy's the first cousin to be elizabeth
figs
cannot produce
berries
the flesh
produces the works of the flesh
the spirit produces the fruits of the
spirit
with the flesh you see
focus on galatians 3 19 again now the
words of the flesh are these adultery
for the occasionally
fine
if satan died tonight
the flesh would still produce those
things
ah
you're not with me you're nice looking
but you're not with me
how can i say that again i say the same
way
let's say the devil dropped dead tonight
from a heart attack are you with me
we'd all rejoice okay
we would still sin
so the works of the flesh are not what
the devil does
it's what
we do
now we don't want to be nice to him but
we can't blame him
now
if the spirit dropped dead and that will
never happen we could not produce love
joy peace long suffering gentleness
goodness be we couldn't do it
because that's the work
of the spirit but all our sins that's
the work of us
it's also biblical
now
let's forget the devil for a minute
we need the spirit of god where
come on come on where
inside in order that he might do what
produce
the fruits of the spirit are not clothes
you wear
they all combine to form a mindset
that's why galatians not galatians
philippians 2 verse 5 tells us let this
mind be in you
which was also in christ jesus
now reason with me a father continues to
be with me i pray please please in jesus
name amen
as a man thinketh in his heart so is he
in the heart there's the mind
if i have the mind of jesus
what kind of speech will i have
the speech of jesus
what kind of thoughts will i have the
thoughts of jesus
what kind of behavior will i have the
behavior of jesus
do you become that overnight no it's a
growing process but we must continually
seek to have the mind of jesus because
the mind of jesus is a very vine it will
produce
there is
we don't have to ask for the mind of the
the flesh we're born with it
our our
purpose now our aim is to get rid of the
flesh in the sense that we get rid of
its dominance
because the flesh will only be destroyed
when this mortal puts on immortality and
this corruptible puts on in corruption
the most converted person still has the
carnal nature
that's why the flesh lusteth against the
spirit and the spirit against the flesh
and these are contrary one to the other
galatians 5 17. we always need to keep
praying and studying and confessing
because there's a constant battle
but god has called the people
to proclaim three messages
the first angel the second angel and the
third have been targeting just the first
and one aspect of that message glove
give glory to god and how do we give
glory to god by allowing the spirit of
god to work through us this was the way
it was in the life of christ go to john
14 quickly then i'll come to close john
14.
john was written by the disciple closest
to christ so it's a very profitable
thing to read the gospel of john and his
epistles and revelation all written by
the same man the gospel of john first
john second john third john revelation
same person
john 14.
let's read from verse 8.
are you there
philip says what
shows the father and it sufficeth us
jesus said unto him have i been so long
time with you and yet hast thou not
known me philip he that have seen me
have seen the father and how says thou
then show us the father now read verse
10 believe is thou not come on that i am
in the father come on and the father in
me keep reading the words that i speak
unto you i speak not of myself finish
the verse
listen to me carefully
everything jesus did
it was effectively the father working
through him
that is submission to god
let me say it again that is submission
to god
now
the christian must function the same way
listen to paul galatians 2 20 you know
it don't go there just say i am
crucified with christ
nevertheless i live yet not i but christ
liveth in me stop
if christ lives in you
the life of christ will emerge
does it emerge overnight no but it
emerges
if satan lives in me the life of satan
but as i said if satan dies i still have
a carnal nature
and that comes out
that's why paul said i am crucified with
christ we have to kill
the dominance of the carnal nature and
that is killed by total surrender we
must die with him literally
that's how we kill the dominance i say
of the carmel nature it will be
eradicated when christ comes the second
time figs cannot produce berries someone
inhabited by the spirit of god cannot
produce that list in galatians 5 19-21
so we have the works of the flesh and we
have the fruits of the spirit
the fruits of the spirit are produced by
the spirit the same way the gifts of the
spirit are produced by the spirit
you missed what i said
go to first corinthians 12 then i'll
stop
12 39 it looks like
i'm stopping i'm stopping
we watch manchester united for five
hours and never get tired
the sermon goes over five minutes and we
call the police all right what book did
i send you to
first corinthians chapter 12 let's read
from verse 8.
for to one is given how
by the spirit the word of wisdom to
another the word of knowledge by the
same spirit to another faith by the same
spirit to another what the gifts of
healing by the same spirit now the
spirit gives these gifts
it is the spirit that produces the fruit
let me tell you something else
the gifts will cease
when this world
ceases the fruits will remain
ah you miss that
we have the gifts of the spirit
name some of them quickly come on give
me one decide
give me a gift
knowledge we just read it give me
another gift
wisdom another one
faith another one
prophecy another one
miraculous powers gifts of healing yes
interpretation of tongues the gift of
tongues discerning of spirits these are
all gifts
they will cease when christ comes back
love
joy
peace long suffering
gentleness goodness faith meekness
temperance the fruits of the spirit
they will last forever
how do we glorify god
we produce fruits but how are the fruits
actually produced by the indwelling of
the spirit of christ
which means
we have to keep christ within
and how do we do that
the word of god
that's why he says in verse 7 of john 15
if ye abide in me
and my words abiding you
you shall ask what you will and it shall
be done unto you because when the word
abide it is the spirit that tells us
what to ask for
figs
do not produce or bear
berries if we're children of god called
as abraham was called the call of
abraham is for us we're called to be a
blessing to glorify god
and to present christ to the world
if the spirit is in us we'll produce the
fruits or the spirit will through us
if the spirit is not the controlling
power in us
the flesh
will do its work
we may look
like things
because we're experts in looking like
the high priest are you following me we
dress nicely and we thank god for
clothes we drive nice cars we thank god
for limousines we thank god for whatever
he gives us
so we look
like angels stranded on the earth
but then when you observe us we display
something else
we want to look like what we claim
so my appeal to you today
as your brother in christ
let's get the spirit into us
and keep the spirit in us how
the word
i'll give you two conditions for getting
the spirit go to luke 11.
then i'll close that's four times i've
said i have closing
maybe a fifth time is coming luke 11
verse 13.
do you have that
all right well if you have it let's read
it
if he then being evil
know how to give good gifts unto your
children how much more shall your
heavenly father give what
come on
to those that what
ask
do you understand what the verse is
the verse compares god with parents
earthly father with the heavenly father
jesus says look you're sinful people
but you still know what's good for your
children
with the corrupt mind you still know
then what about my father
who is sinless
does he know what's good for you yes and
christ says the spirit is the best gift
god can give
now
you ask
someone sent me a text
i
pray for me i need help with tuition
ask
but there's another condition go to acts
chapter 5.
the book of acts
matthew mark luke john x by the way who
can recite all 66 books in order to have
all 66 in order
genesis 2 what's the last book called
revelation okay my good god bless you
all teach your children and in teaching
them you will learn
what book did i say what chapter 5 what
verse 32 read with me my king james
people
and we are
his witnesses of these things and so is
also
the holy ghost come on
whom god hath given to them that obey
obedience
is one condition for receiving the holy
spirit
you obey god by obeying this
there's no other way to obey god you
cannot get around the word of god
and so luke tells us ask
luke tells us also because
luke wrote the book of acts so in two
books he tells us
one he tells us ask luke 11 13 and then
acts 5 32 obey of course
luke also tells us in acts 2 go to acts
2 38
and let's see another condition which
applies to some of you
i am preaching three or four sermons in
one
do you have acts chapter two also
written by luke
let's read from 37 so we get the
connection now when they heard this they
were pricked where
in their hearts uncertain to peter until
the rest of the apostles what
men and brethren come on
now my people with king james what does
verse 38 say
then peter said unto them what repent
and be baptized every one of you in the
name of jesus christ for the remission
of sins finish the verse and ye shall
receive
now what are the three conditions we've
identified one
two
three
which one is get get baptized which one
is lacking in your life don't tell me
ask
that's easy for us to do
obey that takes a lot of
get baptized
if anyone is lacking fill it in
because without the spirit of god
we cannot produce
the berries
we'll be fixed trying to produce berries
it will never work
and so i say again
now the works of the flesh are manifest
which are these and those the works of
the faith think for fake and for flesh
but the fruits of the spirit
are produced
by the spirit
the works of the flesh
are produced not by the devil
they are produced by us because as i
said if the devil dies tonight
there'll be crime in alvarado and
whatever this place is called tomorrow
how many of you will say father
use me
as a fig
to bury by to produce the berries the
fruits of the spirit can i see your hand
let me ask again hands down how many
will say father
grant me your spirit
that the spirit may produce the fruits
in my life can i see your hand
stand up with me
i feel the urge to tell you again
[Music]
i am not defending the devil is that
clear
he's the enemy of god must be my enemy
what i am saying
the devil is not responsible for the
sins we commit
are you with me
they are our choices
temptation is an invitation to which we
have the rsvp
and too often we rsvp immediately
so when the devil said if thou be the
son of god command of these stones we
made bread that was an invitation and
jesus rejected it
he has bowed eyes closed father in
heaven
we thank you for your word
we thank you thank god through the
spirit we can produce the berries the
fruits
because without the spirit we cannot
produce the fruits of the spirit it is
his work in us as we remain consciously
surrendered
father the works of the flesh are the
reason why christ died so painfully
and live such a hard life
where we have misrepresented your father
and i include myself
forgive us their god
give us hatred for sin it is the very
first promise of the bible and i will
put enmity between thee and the woman
between thy seed and her seed put that
enmity in us for sin
and give us love for righteousness
where we've let you down forgive us dear
god and from this point forward
let the blessed berries the fruits of
the spirit be seen in our life that we
like our father abraham might be a
blessing in the little world where we
live
bless our guests bless all the children
be with us again this afternoon father
as we study your word one more time
we pray from our hearts in jesus name
amen before you sit have a call to me
said there are three conditions for
receiving the spirit what were they
how many of you will ask can i say i
have you'll ask let me ask god loves to
give time
what's the second condition
now here's a very
preachers have a right to be nosy let me
be nosy
there's an area in your life where you
were disobedient
you need to cut it out are you with me
there is an area where you and i are
deliberately disturbed we know we're
wrong we keep doing it god wants that to
stop how many will say father by your
grace i want to stop that area of
rebellion can i see your head okay now
three who needs to be baptized
you need to make that decision
just make the decision
which one of you just the decision
you've not yet made
just the decision
to be baptized
all right maybe someone online is
responding let me pray again father
as your people wrestle with decisions
and decisions have to be made
let the spirit move them to the side of
righteousness
right doing and that which pleases you
stay with us there god
when you come save everyone without
losing one
in jesus name i pray let god's blessed
people say amen and amen
you